for joining me now mike pompeo former
secretary of state fox news contributor
mr secretary have you heard from the
speaker since you made your offer
uh laura thanks for having me on i have
not heard from her it was a little bit
tongue-in-cheek and that i'd prefer to
travel with lots of other people
but having said that this is about
america
if the if the speaker of the house now
allows some second-rate chinese foreign
diplomat who says boy we might do
something that's really hard on america
if you're speaker of the house the third
person the third highest ranking federal
official says no you can't come here
we're going to do something we acquiesce
to that threat we're in for a long
decade here in the united states of
america president biden needs to get
serious he needs to defend the things
that matter to the american people from
california to new york florida to
washington
to allow the chinese to just issue a
statement and change the direction
change the actions that the united
states will take because we are fearful
of them uh we we are in for a long
struggle and it will not end well with
that kind of failed leadership yeah so
what message does it send if if we
allow china to dictate the travel of the
woman who's third in line for the
presidency what message does that send
to them
it tells every one of our allies in the
region the japanese the south koreans
the australians it says don't hang with
the americans they're fearful and it
tells our adversaries you mentioned
afghanistan certainly the same thing
happened in ukraine as well we said the
minor incursion would be okay when when
you're not strong when this is a tough
nasty world out there lord where you're
not strong especially again what is the
greatest threat to the american people
today the chinese communist party when
you demonstrate weakness
they are going to walk through the fire
and they're going to make life really
difficult for us it doesn't need to be
that way we're the most powerful nation
in the world we have an economy that is
unrivaled we can beat them we can win
this we can continue to have another 250
good years for america but if a speaker
of the house is just going to travel to
a sovereign nation the nation of taiwan
and the chinese say no we don't think
she should go and you go okay never mind
we're not going to send her that is a
bad and dangerous place to find it it's
um it's just
it's so unbelievable i can't even
believe we're even having to talk about
it but speaking of washed up pentagon
talking heads mr secretary here's
retired army general barry mccaffrey
watch
most people say you shouldn't go uh it's
it's a
thoughtless measure at this point to
have a
politician there i'm not sure
what positive can come out of it and
there there will be some signal some
measure by the chinese in response to
pelosi visits not a good idea
i mean mr secretary i mean is everybody
bought and paid for by china everyone i
mean i'm not saying he is but he
certainly sounds like he is
boy not everyone but too many whether
it's hollywood who acquiesces the same
way biden did right they don't put they
don't put chinese characters in or they
they continue to buy stuff from xinjiang
where they're committing atrocities even
today our biggest corporations in
america there's a lot of folks that are
deeply connected to china in a way
that's not good for the united states
general mccaffery there kind of just
assumes failure he assumes that the
chinese ought to be able to dictate who
can travel where from the united states
what's next you're going to tell leaders
they can't travel someplace else because
the chinese don't like it if they go to
fiji or the solomon islands or wherever
it may be
this is a this is a very dangerous path
to head down we ought to do the things
that matter to america the things that
defend and protect our sovereignty and
our security we can do that we we need
not be fearful we need to be strong and
clear
whether speaker pelosi went or not six
months ago might not have met but once
she said she was going to not go in the
face of a chinese threat demonstrates
where real weakness and real danger
follows i just keep saying the pentagon
told us that the afghan army
could hold their line for what
six months a year
and they collapse in one week so until
we do a retrospective on everything
they've gotten wrong i'm sorry the
leadership not talking about the rank
and file
i mean
we elected a president
to be our commander-in-chief not
millie and austin so that's my view on
that mr secretary great to see you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else